the outlook for Europe does not is not
too good if we look at the Greece fact
the Greek facts and figures we see that
there is a debt ratio of GDP which
exceeds 190 percent for the next year
2014
it's 30 percent more than half a year
ago the IMF had predicted so you see how
bad it really goes but Greece is not the
only problem we do have Spain which is
in a tragic situation the banks have the
government has been negotiating with you
in full another 100 billion euro bailout
to make reforms going but all those
these things have not happened yet the
situation France is not better if you
think it's known well known to everybody
that a couple of very prominent French
people have left their country among
those the actor the pad.you who is now a
Russian citizen I'll no wonder I mean he
doesn't want to pay 75 percent tax
whereas in Russia he only pays 11 flat
the former Chancellor and Prime Minister
has left his own country and is now
living in London with his beautiful wife
Carla so there must be a reason why
those people leave the countries and
France again has also nitin their
reforms the unions are still very strong
there is no entrepreneurship no small
and medium sized enterprises there are
big state owned entities still so
government has a big huge role and this
is one thing that we Europeans have
built over the past couple of decades
bigger and bigger governments more and
more bureaucracy
these things as we all know don't pay
off they don't create economic growth
they don't create productivity they
don't create well-being one country for
example Sweden has shown that one can
turn around very successfully
the Swedes hit their really worst times
in the 90s and so turned around they cut
off the bureaucracy by 25% they
privatized they changed our educational
system into a voucher system they
changed their healthcare system and
right now they are really well off their
that their GDP - that ratio is 36% which
is one of the best ones many other
countries the small countries in Europe
that have survived or have come out of
communism and are now new EU members
they have made reforms they have changed
turned around 180 degrees they have a
capital based pension system they have
flat taxes the EU is the biggest and
right now as it turns out the most
expensive piece project that we see and
eventually it will not keep peace it
will keep or it will start social unrest
so when these things pop up people will
rethink and the European Union as we
know it now will not exist in ten years
trust me
from a free market perspective and from
a very individualist perspective there
will be the rise of regions and there
will be competition among those regions
US policymakers can learn the following
from Europe
don't become Europe and don't don't
copy-paste our socialist solutions and
rather stick to the principles of the
founding fathers stick to your
constitution stick to individual freedom
the rule of law and really prevent your
citizens from big government
institutions from the fourth layer in
society from bureaucracy in again there
is no productivity in this and we can
only create growth and well-being for
everybody if we are productive
well our idea of helping people are
making them acquainted with free market
ideas is for example a free-market
Roadshow and this year we will tour 24
capitals starting in May in Tbilisi
going down to Turkey Greece and all the
countries ending up in in Spain and
Portugal at the end of June and what we
will discuss there with international
economists with business people with
opinion leaders is their charity
programs and the future of Europe
unemployment youth unemployment which is
a serious issue than teittleman's
generation and how to overcome this you
can find out about the free-market
Roadshow at WWF remarket /rs stuff